we now know how to differentiate and
integrate treating metric functions
which is great it's a big wide open
universes different means we can do once
we are able to access these ideas we've
been focusing on the theory so far you
know it's like well why is the
derivative of the sine cosine what about
all of the other trig functions but now
we want to use them in particular
situations where the question is not
just differentiate this or integrate
that where we want to use the
derivatives or integrals in some
particular way so the main applications
were going to go on are one that you
might remember from earlier on this year
when we were thinking about what what
was integration meant to be the answer
for it was a tool to solve a particular
kind of problem namely area now once we
got to area we also extended that into
volume I'm going to leave that off for
now because there's so much to work out
in area that well you'll see why in a
second
so all of these things here are things
that I want you to remember from when we
were teammate integration and area I
wonder if they ring a bell because when
we think about trigonometric integrals
these all become very important to think
about carefully so I'll give you the
first word because you already told me
it it's air get output this is area
right now you start off with the very
very simplest areas where the area is
bound between a curve and and the x-axis
is what we started off we also have a
look at the y-axis eventually so when
you look at a curve and the x-axis
another way of saying that is it's
beneath the curve right so the first
kind is the area beneath whoops isn't it
beneath okay but in addition to that
sometimes you didn't compare one curve
to the axis sometimes you connected
compared a curve to another curve in
which case you would say it's the area
between curves right
they're here between coasts now this is
really important don't worry about
drawing this but when you think about
trig functions this is really really
tricky because when you have a think
about say here's sine and then here's
say cosine right when you think about
the area between these two curves it's
really tricky to think about this shape
here right it's a weird-looking shape
you have to be very careful with finding
out where is this and where is this so
you have to go back to a lot of your
trigonometric knowledge just like we had
to use identities when we were doing
some of our derivatives and integrals so
it becomes tricky that's why I'm drawing
your attention to it again now this
diagram is just as good an opportunity
to say there's another thing you had to
watch out for when you integrate
integration actually works out more than
just area it works out area dependent on
where you are right do you remember that
some of these areas are going to render
a different number compared to others
depending on their position do you
member we call that we call it's signed
area because if you're above the axis
you're positive that's what we used to
but if you're beneath the axis you're
negative so signed area is a really
important idea and because the trig
functions go up and down between
positive and negative this is obviously
going to be very important now lastly I
know it's a bit of a mouthful but when
you're working out these areas right
you're not going to work out this area
for instance as just the integral from
of sine X minus cos x
for starters causes on top of it anyway
you would actually want it from a
particular spot to another particular
spot so what kinds of integrals do we
call that we call them definite
integrals we need like a boundary like
PI on 4 & 3 PI over 4
actually I think it's 5.4 from memory so
therefore you need to think about
everything you know about those definite
integrals right and we looked in quite a
lot of detail at all the different rules
and theorems around these we called them
the remember recording of the properties
of definite integrals stuff like what
happens when you integrate an interval
you integrate it backwards remember what
that happens if you go from like
you know a big value to a small value
run the other way around what happens to
that integral if you do an integral
backwards we need to revise our
properties of different integrals there
are two in particular that it kind of
come up again and again with regard to
trig functions and they are does n
remember what's starting with an S trig
functions are going to be really
important for example do you see that
area up there that's clearly going to be
the same size as the area down here
right do you agree with that what do you
call it when you've got lots of things
that are symmetry thank you very much
you will fight the symmetry all over
your trigonometric functions and their
shapes so therefore if you want to work
out areas you can take advantage of
symmetry there was another thing which
is that I'll give you this one because
people who weren't in my class before
won't remember
dissection was just my word for when you
when you have to slice up an integral
into many different sections when you
dissect it you're like I need to work
out this integral this one's going to be
negative this one for absolute values or
whatever you have to be very very
careful with these